after becoming so invested in the story
and characters it's hard to move on from
Game of Thrones
but the producers writers and actors
behind the series have left Westeros
behind for new projects and it looks
like there's no going back
here's why you shouldn't expect a game
of Thrones sequel anytime soon ready for
a season 9 of Game of Thrones what about
his health
HBO President of Programming Casey boys
is on record as having been willing to
back many more seasons of the smash hit
series but instead of forcing the show
to continue indefinitely he allowed the
creative team to make the ultimate
decision regarding when it would end
apparently showrunners David Benioff and
DB Weiss knew how they wanted the ending
to go for a long time and boys let them
wrap things up on their terms and that
ending it seems is pretty definitive
when asked about potential sequel series
that may be in the works boys told The
Hollywood Reporter nope nope nope no
part of it is I do want this show to be
its own thing I don't want to take
characters from this world that they did
beautifully and put them off into
another world with someone else creating
it in other words don't hold out hope
for that REO goes West spin-off author
george RR martin is supposed to be
working diligently on the winds of
winter but he's also found time to
publish several books plotting out
hundreds of years of Westerosi history
there is a wealth of material set in the
past and HBO has flirted with adapting
more than a few stories for television
if we forget where we've been and what
we've done we're not men anymore just
animals of the possible projects one
prequel series is definitely moving
ahead with a pilot being filmed in an
announced cast list that includes Naomi
Watts and Josh white house the
as-yet-unnamed prequel series will take
place thousands of years before the
events of Game of Thrones as it
chronicles the world's descent from the
Golden Age of Heroes into its darkest
hour there's little word on the other
projects in development which may well
never come to fruition but if one
spin-off proved successful chances are
more will follow further prequels could
follow the events of Martin's fire and
blood which details how King Aegon the
dragon conquered Westeros with his royal
sisters another prequel series could
also adapt some of the tales collected
in the short story volume a night of the
Seven Kingdoms which follow a towering
hedge knight named Duncan who's an
ancestor of Brienne of Tarth traveling
with and defending a little Targaryen
prince by the name of Aegon v or simply
egg there's still more material and
Westeros is history that seems perfect
for television the Blackfyre rebellion
the Targaryen Civil War the dark tale of
the night's king and that's just events
from Westeros Essos has a long and
storied history - when it comes to
stories set in the past martin has given
HBO quite a bit to work with Game of
Thrones viewers became accustomed to the
visual splendor of each episode over the
course of eight seasons each episode is
like its own full-fledged film brought
to life with reality defying
special-effects lavish costuming sets
built the scale and massive casts of
extras as you might imagine filming a
season's worth of small movies can get
pretty expensive the final season
reportedly cost an estimated 15 million
dollars per episode it takes a lot of
money to make dragons fly direwolf's
growl and whites reanimate HBO can
afford to make entire series for fifteen
million dollars rather than shelling out
15 million for a single episode another
game of Thrones scale series especially
one that brought back the same
increasingly expensive cast members
might be a bit too much of a financial
burden to be worth mounting it wasn't
just about the money what was it was it
as the final credits roll on Game of
Thrones a new era begins high fantasy
has proven itself to be extremely
profitable so HBO and the BBC have
teamed up to make another fantasy show
based on a beloved book series His Dark
Materials political struggles check
mysterious powers
check cgi animals check it isn't a game
of Thrones sequel but it may satisfy
some of the same viewers who tuned in to
watch the fantasy unfold plus if you're
tired of fantasy lands there are plenty
of other shows that HBO has cooking that
explored different genres Westworld has
another season on the way for those of
the convoluted sci-fi loving persuasion
fans of superheroes and contemplative
graphic novels can rejoice in the
upcoming premiere of The Watchmen
adaptation Jordan Peele and JJ Abrams
are producing Lovecraft Country a horror
drama that's almost guaranteed to be a
hit even now that we're done watching
Thrones there are plenty of shows on the
way that will make your HBO subscription
worth it even before the dust settled on
Game of Thrones showrunners DB Weiss and
David Benioff set their sights on a
galaxy far far away
CEO Bob Iger has confirmed that after
the twin sunset on the current trilogy
of Star Wars films Benioff and Weiss
will be working on the next series of
films a trilogy telling a new story
separate from the Skywalker saga the
first of the three films is due at the
end of 2020 to giving audiences plenty
of time to forget how upset they were at
the final Game of Thrones season with
two of the largest creative engines for
Game of Thrones headed to space it
doesn't seem like a throne sequel is in
the cards at least not from then Game of
Thrones has changed television as we
know it it's no longer satisfactory for
shows to be small with dedicated
followings every show wants to be a
blockbuster and in the coming years
there will be no limit to the number of
titles seeking to fill the void that the
end of Game of Thrones has left in our
hearts His Dark Materials isn't the only
fantasy adaptation on the table Netflix
is launching a series based on the
Witcher series of books which has
previously been adapted into a very
successful video game franchise Amazon
reportedly paid close to 250 million
dollars for a Lord of the Rings prequel
series meanwhile Netflix is also
planning a live-action version of the
beloved animated series avatar at The
Last Airbender every major company is
trying to replicate the G ot success and
with a competition that's crowded it's
unlikely that a game of Thrones sequel
would really stand out check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]